- Un campus flambant
neuf au coeur de Toron
L'Université de l'Ontario
français a été inaugurée
en grande pompe avec
la présence de plusieurs
personnalités politiques.
GINETTE PETITPAS-TAYLOR,
ministre des Langues officie
- Il y a finalement
une institution au coeur
de l'Ontario par et pour
- Cette institution est
une revendicatiogugugugugue date
dans la province et le chemin
vers sa création a été
tumultueux.
DIANE ADAM, présidente,
Conseil de gouvernance, UOF
- Aujourd'hubobobobobobobobobobg
que la période de gestation
a été long
- Près de trois ans après le
jeudi noir des Franco-Ontariens,
avait mis sur la sellette
le projet de création
de l'UOF, conduisant à de vastes
manifestations dans la
l'aboutissement d'un partenaria.
CAROLINE MULRONEY, ministre
des Affaires francophones
nos collèges et instituions
universitaires, ont un rôle
primordial à jouer afin
de non seulement remédier
du marché du travail...
- Le décor est moderne,
les espaces communs, spacieux
et peuvent accueilPoPoPoPoPoPoP,
150 ont fait leur rentrée
cet automne, majoritairement en
virtuel, car 75 % des étudiants
Dieudonné, lui, vient
par les programmes,
co n n n n n n numériques,
économie et innovation sociale,
qu'il juge novateurs
DIEUDONNÉ KIAMA, étudianten culs
- Les programmes tels que
c'comment dirais-je, originaux.
- Natacha est Torontoise.
Elle a hâte de connaître
la pleine effervescence
NATACHA ADJAKY, étudiante en
économtitititititition sociale
- J'ai parlé avec une fille
et on s'entend très bien,
chez elle, c'est loin.rnrnrnrnrs
été de tout repos pour
la jeune institution, quiecececr
des étudiants canadiens.RERERERF
- Il faut être patient,
il faut savoir  que le cycle
prendre trois ans, quatre ans.
ntntntntntntntnt, on mise sur
l'immigration et on prépare
le terrain auprès de la jeunesse
haut et fort ses couleurs.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ici Camille Feireisen,